you
hi everyone is Gerry Aman leaches org
and I just got paired up playing a 5-2
game now let's try a French see what we
get
hmm okay so I'm guessing that white is
going straight in for a King's Indian
set up I'm not going to be too quick to
Castle kingside
I don't really feel like committing my
king so early so let's get Bishop e7 in
knight c6 pretty Universal squares for
these guys and this is where I'm not
going to Castle and instead I believe
Queen c7 is a useful move so I'm going
to do that and also b6 and I'm expecting
e5 at some point which case I'll drop my
Knight to d7 and then I could consider
Bishop b7 queenside castle
this may be an idea I am NOT completely
against castling kingside I may I may go
Kings side now that white has made some
pawn move on this side they've weakened
d3 I could be sure that there's these
moves coming if I Castle kingside
starting first with e5 council e 597
Queen e2 hmm I'm still gonna I think I'm
still going to hold off on on committing
my king let's get another useful move in
Bishop b7 I'm a hesitant to play a5
Bishop a6 to pinpoint here because of a4
alright now that that move has been
played hmm let's see
maybe I could even get away with one
more useful move I think h6 is useful
even one Castle kingside although it
could be a potential sacrifice with this
Knight
okay well they've clearly played on the
Queen side now so I feel a bit more
comfortable with castling kingside but
let me first secure my knight on c6 and
okay so the bishop has been pulled away
from this diagonal so now only at this
point moved 12 am i a bit more
comfortable with castling kingside
and now the rooks where do they belong
I guess we'll put one here and the other
one on c8 not sure maybe the B file okay
tension is maintained for some time now
I don't improve well I think I don't
think I should release the tension let's
get one more piece working I don't want
to take here because it helps both the
rook and Bishop after a recapture uh-huh
finally some structural shift and maybe
I could look forward to b5 Knight b6
night a4 mmm things are heating up
isn't that dropping a pawn though could
take here or I could push gives up efore
well either the capture the push is
going to give up efore I don't want to
allow this and then a push so I'm gonna
play here and try to play against the
bishop I'm threatening the pawn on b4
now I think and actually have an
interesting decision oh it's not
expecting that one I don't know that
that's right because I'm gonna take and
then play my knight here kind of watch
out for this night at night c4 move and
I will see so far uh pretty oh I totally
missed that one it's gonna say so far a
pretty patient game by both of us this
may not be the end of the world actually
because this isn't the healthiest of
pawns but my knight right here isn't
isn't so great I guess he could be
chopped up soon I'm gonna go here I
could probably take the knight you know
be good for them they'll have a passed
pawn maybe a connected passed pawn
did consider rook to a8 but I was
fearful of this move you know so I'm
down upon but I have something that I am
currently biting at I wonder about d4 I
would like to have light square bishop
Soph because maybe I could play against
their King position some they have a
couple holes in their position h3 and f3
I have a fine structure down upon but
still a fine structure what's remaining
of it
if D for this is maybe vulnerable my
bishop
okay well I
consider 9b3 they are nb6 I don't have
very many options hmm maybe we could
take I know well I can't drop b6 I think
I have to take here and maybe get my
knight doing something target the a pawn
let's go for this
I think Queen B 2 is a pretty convenient
way to defend I need to get this guy
working
all right I don't see a better square
for my queen rook takes rook I don't
know if I want to take with my rook I
want to keep pressure on the apon okay
that's a pretty convenient way to defend
alright I think I'm gonna go for this
regrouping a knight on f5 yeah so
they're ready to kick my knight away to
watch out for this square here even as a
pawn sacrifice this might be something
just open up the diagonal rook pivoting
here takes takes suppose a queen is here
there's mating ideas on g7 for the
moment their Bishop on b2 is restricted
but I wouldn't identified as really
inconvenienced okay well we know where
that knight is headed I'm going to take
the bishop because I want to keep
pressure on this pawn however they could
still jump in there huh all right let's
get into f5 they've weakened their King
position they're vulnerable to checks on
the diagonal at the moment
well they keep my knight out of f5 I
don't know I might meet g4 with h5 just
as a pawn sacrifice to grant my knight
the f5 Square and we'll see still tight
hmm I guess the queen is eyeing up c64
when my knight moves hmm okay maybe I go
about it I give up on the pressure
against a3 because I really don't see me
tracking this pawn down so I'm gonna try
something different
hmm suppose right now I go for the
doubling can I seize control over this
only open file what's what's happening
soon is probably a4 a5 actually maybe
this is a good move come to think of it
I think my queen on a4 can be quite
disruptive hitting the knight pressure
on everything on the Queen side and I
know I have this square but I don't want
to be too quick to give up the c6 square
because this is a base point I have to
take some care over this hone it's under
2 minutes ok well this is going to be a
little bit tricky for them now hmm
just like to double you know that's
going for a double it's gonna do this
but I could take some care over this
square
let's get doubled I don't know that I
want to take with my queen
maybe maybe I do take with my queen
hmm now got to make a quick decision my
rook and Knight and do well to control
these two even if my Queen moves forward
she is still watching out for Queen ay
ay
how does the rook it active I don't know
I could be a great bother in defending
d1 with my queen
so okay kind of drawn towards me well I
should move fast let's get my queen
active this is an unprotected piece if
they go further they give up f5 I like
my position even though I'm down upon
still feel like I have something good
coordination pieces are defended there
are some loose pieces of rook that's not
playing they have the more vulnerable
Queen definitely not allowing a queen
exchange hmm come to think of it maybe I
should have done this okay that really
kills my pieces I didn't really see that
move hmm because now what's my knight
gonna do hmm well I think I'm gonna try
to get active like this along the D file
this pawn moves that would be really
nice okay yeah you know I don't think I
don't think I have anything around the D
file they got the the key squares
covered maybe Queen on a8 is the best
spot they're gonna go for though hmm I
should have played h5 I'm having some
regret here yeah that move is coming in
I think I have to do this maybe I should
have done it even earlier I have to
break open the Kings side I need to get
a square for my pieces my knight this
might still be good
even as a pawn sacrifice because it
gives them a connected past pawn on d5
their knight is pinned on pawn takes
pawn I'm going to be taking with my
knight and he's within checking distance
so now there's some restriction okay my
bishop can now play as well as a
dual-purpose move come to think of it
the jeep on move Bishop is now putting
pressure on the pawn
let's be on the lookout for some tactics
I still feel that their king is the more
vulnerable we're catching up on time
evening out on time I guess we take
their uh yeah sure
okay we're going to go here I guess
uh I don't know maybe that wasn't the
right decision don't see I push that
pond and get away with it hmm yeah
they're hunting that pond down aren't
they
rook takes is good all right
mmm don't really have anything I think
my knight needs to come over here and
still take a couple moves for their
queen to get to one of these two and
challenge the blockade I guess here or
maybe my knight on this square gotta go
fast and then you hear trying to disrupt
things and they're gonna push I don't
know what that move is doing hello boy I
know I'm in trouble yeah they got me
right here hon takes
I got nothing pawn pushes good or that
yeah I should just resign I played well
mmm I'm really regretting not playing h5
sooner I don't know why didn't better
appreciate their pawn on g4 and
thereupon an h5 restricting my knight
because I would have liked to have gone
about it where I didn't have to play g6
it weakens my position I know I get some
squares for my pieces but I should just
go about it with h5 yeah so let's go
into it see how we could improve some so
yeah I've played in the black end of
this more than the white end and more
often than that I'll go straight in for
a castles at right around this moment
move seven but you really need to know
how exactly to expand on the Queen side
when you do this because we got this
stuff happening for white
you could hit this pawn a few times but
it's going to be secured and then you
have to kind of play in the Queen side
where you have the space meanwhile what
is white doing there's these pretty
Universal moves h4 oops okay it just
came up with the graph here where was I
at Queen c7 okay so I was pointing out
if I'm to castle on this move seven
there's e5 Knight here rook there
multi-purpose to defend and vacate f1 I
could add more pressure but it's
defended and then expanding this Knight
goes for a little journey I'm not
certain of these exact moves I've seen a
five I've seen Bishop a six
I think b4 is a move Knight h2 Bishop
here and I mean there's a lot of pieces
drifting over near my Kings side who is
lacking some minor piece defense this
pawn is super disruptive it may be the
case that I shouldn't go all in with
these pawn moves and maybe take a
timeout for h6
I don't know the DD of the details but
this is basically what I wanted to avoid
and it's why I'm choosing Queen c7 here
and not yet committing my king so should
if I be played here instead of c3 my
king isn't over here and I could always
consider if it should be seven let's
just say he goes over here I could
consider queenside castle and maybe even
look to expand some on the King side
with h6 and g5
so a lot of patience and I think for
both of us in this game when there was
this pond tension okay let me get back
to the actual game here there we go
so c3 was played Bishop p7 a 3 and B 4
is quite common I think I'm fine with
how I played it up to this point so
right around here
I feel like this is really the spot
where I could improve I don't know yeah
this is this is really a key moment or
there's still this tension between these
guys I think it's fine with what I did
getting both rooks here but certainly
right around here I mean I'm dropping a
pond now I pushed and then b4 yeah I
totally missed this idea I guess I have
to maybe just move my knight at this
point well I'm wondering if there's
something right around here
even after Queen to e2 okay I need a
computer so what can I say I'm not sure
what the suggestion will be ah I never
even considered really capturing yeah
and why not hmm I could go straight in
for a capture on e4 even at this moment
it's suggesting it yeah I should
consider capturing right now and then
there would be no question like you know
this is another way to view it I'm
moving a rook to the D file that I'm not
absolutely certain is going to be open
so why not have that you know why not
let that first be known for sure that
the D files can open up before
committing my rip to the D file that's
maybe a way I could have looked at it
capturing first clearly the D file is
now half opened and I get play against
this poem just as I did in the game but
it was quickly converted to a C pond
okay so this is this is an improvement
let me just quickly just kind of doing a
blunder check I don't believe there are
any blunders missed but I just want to
keep a close eye as if right through and
make sure that there wasn't anything
serious happening now so I was right
around equal and this is where I can
make an improvement with capturing first
okay so noted
I could have captured first but even at
this point here there's some more
improvements I could be capturing on C
for I'm trying to recall what was it
about this capture that I did not like I
don't know that I really even have an
answer to that I know is mentioning
whether I push or capture I'm giving up
efore hmm oh you know what it well you
know what it was I I didn't I didn't
want the C file to open up but what
happened in the game it still opened up
and they were able to take advantage of
my queen position even suggest taking
with the night instead okay okay so I
should be capturing here and c4 and then
I could go in for the win of the beep on
hitting it three times it's only
defended once so I really didn't make
the correct decisions in these tense
moments where there was this pond
tension I could have made this
improvement capture first before
declaring my rook to the D file
capturing on C for these critical moves
critical moments in the game pawn
captures and I make good decisions here
I shouldn't have captured their cuz in
the end I'm losing a pond but even so
you know they could snip my knight I
thought that this was a this would be a
good decision because even if even if I
end up getting this pawn back
let's just say this and yeah this movie
even if I'm getting this this is a
tremendous asset and my pawns are weak
material is balanced but light still has
a little bit of space which I don't
think is that much of a positive in this
queenless position where my King isn't
going to come under any heavy fire this
is a position that's now more directed
towards the Queen side and I have these
vulnerable points on a 5 and C 5 and
there's just a wonderful square for the
knight on C for putting pressure on a 5
so these guys will be targeted they
didn't go for that exchange but it was
certainly an option here and there's
just a continual light maintains an
advantage from here on out upon plus
it's still a little bit tricky wants to
go straight in for a knight f5 I'm gonna
have fun advantage what was it saying
right around here Queen c7 okay takes
takes and now I got active with my queen
and they played h5 so okay well even g6
right here took me a while to even
realize that I could be playing g6 to
get my pieces active but let me just
look at this moment here after g4 cuz I
was pointing out that I really wanted to
play this hmm okay and the computers
eyes not so great ooh giving up that
square and it could be pounced on right
away threatening me
okay yeah I don't have time to kind of
seal that up do I on g6 there's context
I thought but there's even something
better whoo yeah my night is really
struggling isn't he Oh can you check and
then Queen over that's not a fun
position and look at these gaps look at
these holes f6 yeah so it's not quite
working out so I guess h5 wasn't a good
reply to it and but once h5 is in this
is the moment where I was probably
floundering I couldn't really find a
plan just going over to the D file
doubling up and then coming back over
there so clearly a bit planless around
this stage I should be looking to get my
knight active and I only realized that
this is a way to do it much too late my
queen is fine right here pinning the
knight and if given a moment white
didn't white never too loud this but I
would really like to post up right in
the center here with my queen rook d3
and start having some influence along
the third-ranked but I didn't come up
with the g6 move soon has it as equal
okay at this point here going for g6
yeah because as mentioned I mean I am
down upon but I felt like at least my
King was a bit more on the safe side you
know this Knight with in checking
distance f4 is an idea for the night
it's good it's a good move getting out
of the Knights check and unpinning the
knight yeah
pushing through okay how could I have
hunted this pawn down oh I did have a
moment for Queenie for ah well that's
tough there's a lot of calculation here
because my mind was set on blockading
this guy from running mmm
yeah there's a bit to calculate here
isn't there
with Queenie for suppose they push and I
have to do this kind of stuff rook b6
computer going a little crazy town um
okay fill me in oh yeah sure okay yeah I
saw that one okay okay but clear that
clearly some mm calculation was needed
right around this point at a point where
neither of us really had any time oh I
could just take the pawn with my rook oh
man why didn't I see that I don't have
an answer I don't know why I didn't see
rook takes pawn here huh oh wow what a
blind spot that was I could just take
the beep on and wow we have quite a game
still still to come
wow I just totally didn't see that I
could grab the beep on I'm just gone
after this the upon lives and queens not
having fun being a block hater no one
would
yikes and I could even go in for that
right away I don't need the bishop
support Bishop takes Knight I could take
here
okay well I should have seen this forget
about the clock i this should have only
taken a second of thought to see that I
could grab the pond mm-hmm oh well okay
well as usual I hope you're able to take
something away from this especially the
opening part here I know it's something
again I've gone straight in for before
quite natural to just go in for our
castles right at this point but it may
be worthwhile or you know something to
consider where you can make some pretty
Universal moves Queen c7 b6 get all your
minor pieces out and hold off on your
king position for the moment wait for
whites and maybe commit some pawn
advances on the Queen side before
committing your king even going as far
as securing your night after a b4 and
that last detail before even committing
the rook how about making sure the D
file is first open before applying her
to d8 anyhow as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now
take care
you